قال ناجون فلسطينيون في غزه ان جنود جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكبوا مجازر في
احياء من مدينه غزه ووصفوا معاناتهم مع
قوات الاحتلال بالجحيم وقد اظهرت الصور
مشاهد دمار شامل حيث لم تتمكن فرق الاسعاف
من الوصول الى تلك الاماكن لتقديم
المساعده للجرحى وانتشال الجثث من تحت
الانقاض الصحفي جهاد ابو شنب رصد جانبا من
معاناه سكان غز مع الحصار الذي فرضته قوات
الاحتلال على
مناطقهم نحن الان عند مفترق ضبيط في شارع
الجلاء هذه المنطقه التي كانت تتواجد فيها
قوات الاحتلال لمده ست ايام ست ايام كنا
محاصرين داخل المنازل لم نستطع الخروج
وثقنا العديد من الشهادات من خلال النوافذ
الضيقه في المنزل الذي كنا نتواجد فيه
وثقنا شهاده عائز الجنود رايناهم باعيننا
وهم يتمشون في الشوارع ايضا الياته
ودباباته كانت تتواجد في هذه المنطقه بشكل
بشكل كثيف وبشكل كبير يقومون باطلاق نار
بشكل كبير وثقنا العديد من الشهادات
المهمه التي يجب ان تصل الى العالم عن حجم
جرائم قوات الاحتلال التي ارتكبتها في هذه
المنطقه قاموا بتجريد كل شيء كما نرى ايضا
خلفي يتواجد جمعيه الشبان المسيحيه التي
سقط فيها اكثر من 12 شهيدا حتى الان جسس
ما زالت موجوده داخل الجمعيه لم يستطع
الوصول الوصول لهم احدا ايضا المباني تم
احراقها من الداخل تجريف المنا زل اطلاق
القذائف بشكل مستمر كما نرى هذا هو شارع
الجلاء هنا مفترق ضبيط ايضا وهنا ايضا
شارع الوحده العائلات التي كانت محاصره ما
زالت تحاول الخروج من المنطقه باتجاه غرب
مدينه غزه ايضا شارع شارع الجلاء باتجاه
مفترق الصرايا كما نرى حجم الدمار ايضا
شارع الوحده باتجاه مجمع الشفاء الطبي هذا
المكان الذي تم قصفه هي شهيد شهيد وهي
شهيد فيش جرافات فيش كباشات الشهداء هيك
زي ما انت شايف بظلهم على الحاله هذه
اسبوع 10 ايام ماحدش ددور مش انه ما حد ب
لانه فيش اليات فيش معدات فيش طرق تسعف
الناس وتق الناس وتتف صاروا الشهداء في
غزه يروا الشوارع زي ما انت شايف ما حد
مدو اج الدبابات هنا واليهود جرفه وكسروا
وخبطه نزوا الحيطه هذه الناس هنا فوق ال
150 نفر م 200 نفر عددهم نسوان واطفال
ورجال لقيناهم سابوهم وراحوا بعد شويه اف
16 ضربتهم رجعوا ثاني الدبابات دفنوهم هم
احياء وهم ميتين دفنوا عليهم كمان الصور
نزلوه عليهم وردم عليهم وهم يستغيثوا وحتى
اسم هم يستغيثوا اسمع اطلاق نار كمان
عليهم وقعدوا يزعقوا عليه نفس وين نزلهم
مش قاعدين ننزلهم احنا قرنا على الدفاع
المدني خلصت بطريه الجوال وفرنا على
الدفاع المدني انه يجي يستغيثوا بس
الدبابات كانت موجوده والضرب والخبط وكان
ما في ولا ط كان طخ عليهم هم زين طخ زي
مجنين لقيت مراه غادت هي وطفل صغير رضيع
راسهم رايح فيش رس لهم مقطع روؤسهم جبناهم
ودفنهم اهليهم دفنه هناك في الارض الواده
اللي غادت وهاي اللي
صار